Çok
teşekkür ederim
Merhaba arkadaşlar o
ilk dedi konuşmam ve 38. yaşamın ilk
gününde sizlerle burada birlikte
olmaktan da çok mutluyum çok teşekkür
ederim Benim için de çok güzel bir
sürpriz oldu
Evet bugünkü konumuz ekran uyutabiliriz
mümkün mü acaba
abone ol
bu götürmüyor musun
mi Evet esasında bugünkü konumuz Meslek
seçiminde coğrafya kadermidir sağ olsun
Arif hocam ve ben bir fuarda tanışmıştım
fuarda şirketimizi temsil ederken
kendisi bana son Birkaç soru sormuştu
ondan sonra biz esasında kendisi davet
etti benim kendisine de çok teşekkür
ederim
[Müzik]
büyüt emiyorsa çok sorun değil
Ama sanırım dondu
devam et
Evet Tamam yeterli oldu Teşekkür ederim
Meslek seçiminde coğrafya kadermidir bu
konuyu tartışacağız arkadaşlar tabii
burada
bu sorunun cevabını Ben sunumun en
sonunda vermek istiyorum ben bir Eğitmen
değilim Kusura bakmayın bütün bugün
konuşma yapacak arkadaşlarımızın tamamı
Eğitmen Arkadaşlar ben onları kadar bu
konuda başarılı olmaya bilirim ama ben
size neler yaptım neler yaşadım bu
süreçte onların tamamına değinmek
istiyorum öncelikle
bu nasıl Meslek tercihi yaptım
Üniversite döneminde ilk Hayallerim
neydi İş hayatım ve hatalarım neler oldu
bunlar üzerine konuşmak istiyorum
Ben hem anne tarafından hem de baba
tarafından tarımsal kökenli bir aileden
Geliyorum anne tarafım ve tarımsal
mekanizasyon üzerine saban pulluk Çapa o
dönemi mekanizasyon ları babam ise
tamamen çiftçilikle üreticilik ile
uğraşan bir aileden gelme ancak
ülkemizin ilk ve mühendislerinden ve ilk
gübre kimyevi gübreler i bulup
Çiftçilere uykuda uygulatan insanlardan
tabii ki
ben de çocukluktan beri tarımın
içerisindeyim bahçelerin içerisinden ve
en güzel anılarımız pamuk yılların
üzerinde ve portakal tarlalarında
bahçelerinde geçti şimdi üniversite son
dönemine geldiğimizi Pardon lisenin son
dönemine geldiğimizde artık bir Meslek
tercihi yapmak zorundaydık
Üniversite sınavlarına Hazırlanıyoruz
Öncelikle kendime sordum ben ne
yapabilirim ben ne biliyorum ben
çocukluktan beri Portakalı gördüğüm
zaman üzerindeki zararlının ne olduğunu
on yaşından beri bilen bir insandım o
yüzden şunu düşündüm Ben çevreme nasıl
faydalı olurum ben Ziraat Mühendisi
olursam çevreme faydalı olabilirim diye
düşündüm ve ilk tercih olarak Ziraat
fakültesini tercih ettim o dönemde
arkadaşlarımızın tamamı Fenomen
meslekleri tercih ediyor dua besleme
besleyeceğim mesleği ben bunları
kesinlikle meslek ayırt etmem Evet Ee
ben Ziraat fakültesini tercih ediyordum
bir grup arkadaşım da sadece aldığı
puanı odaklanmıştı Yani ben bu puan
alırsam şuraya gitmek istiyorum O da
esasında tamamen bir kere kapağı atmakla
oluşan bir şeydir neden bu ailelerden
gelen bir şey işte ben 100 puan alırsam
şuraya gideceğim 200 puan alırsam buraya
geleceğim neden aile bir baskılar
üniversiteye bir kere kapat ondan
sonrası kolay esasında değil
göreceksiniz Biz hayatta en kolay şey
üniversiteyi kazanmak Önemli olan Ondan
sonraki iş hayatı
ben bu nedenle bu kapak atma teorisini
çok tehlikeli buluyorum arkadaşlar Peki
neler yapabiliriz
Biz doktora dönemi boyunca
derslerimde pedagojik formasyon ders
almıştım ve orada bir tane ödevim vardı
bu ödevle çok ilgimi bir şey çekti karın
James egzersizi burada diyor ki bir kedi
olsanız V9 yanınızda 1.9 meslek
seçeceksiniz bunlardan hangilerini
seçersiniz burada özellikle tüm
mesleklerin hepsi eşit seviyelere
kesinlikle bir tanesi bir tanesinden
farklı değil ve günün sonunda hepsinden
aynı parayı kazanıyorsunuz hepsi aynı
Prestij de size herhangi bir miras
kalmıyor ve zengin biriyle evlenmiyorsun
arkadaşlar peki böyle bir durumda dokuz
mesleği Yazdığınız zaman ilk üç
Mesleğiniz ne olurdu öncelikle Bunu
kendinize soruyorsunuz büyük 3 meslek
işte sizin ileride başarılı
olabileceğiniz meslek Ben kendime
sorduğumda yine Ziraat fakültesini
tercih etmiştim Arkadaşlar
bu tabi
üniversiteyi kazandım birinci sınıftayım
Bir sınıfta gündüzleri okula giderken
işçi ders bitimlerinde babamın yanına
gidiyordum O dönemlerde arkadaşlar gibi
üretiyordu qbook 2002'de bir de
veriyorsun oldu bu devalüasyonda fosfor
bu ve Türkiye'deki Volkswagen kilogram
kilogramı 60 liradan 120 liraya çıkmıştı
bu ofise gittiğimde Babam da sadece şunu
gördüm artık bir gibi üretimini
bırakıyoruz bırakmamızı sebebi bu
devalüasyonlar the artık mücadele edemez
olmuştur rakiplerimiz de ben dedim ki
gidelim bulalım yani nerede fosfor var
şimdi var gidelim alalım ürdün'den var
gidelim alalım yok dedi ki üretim o
şekilde değil Eğer üretiyor San sadece
senin elinde olmalı sadece Sense
atmalısın O yüzden yerel kaynakların
tamamı ülkelere bağlıdır ve dev
şirketlere bağlıdır Sadece onlar
istediklerine satarlar ve istedikleri
fiyattan satarlar Bu nedenle üretim
yapmadığı sürece seni de yapabileceğim
hiçbir şey yok
Peki ben ne yaptım Bir sınıf bitiyor 2.
sınıf döneminde bir aile dostumuzun bir
fide üretim şirketi kurduğunu duydum
üretim olunca kafama kazandı Ve gittim
direkt randevu aldım ilk başta beni
kabul etmediler Çünkü a bir şey yoktu
Bir diplomam yoktu dedim ki ben vasıfsız
personel olarak çalışmak istiyorum Beni
Seray'a alın Ne gerekiyorsa ben
yapacağım ve vasıfsız personel olarak
sırada işletmeye fide üretiminde üretime
başladım orada sağolsun Ziraat Mühendisi
abilerimiz Ablalarımız bana mesleğim
sevdirdiler bir genel müdürümüz vardı bu
genel müdürümüz bir gün seraları
gezerken bana dedi ki abi Sen ne yapmak
istiyorsun dedi ki ben Üretim yapmak
istiyorum Neden Üretim yapmak istiyorsun
üretim yaparsam her şey benim elimde
fiyatına Ben belirlerim satacağım
kişiyle Ben bilirim Peki öğreteceksin
Vallahi benim şu an sadece fide üretimi
biliyorum fide üretim peki dedim neden
pazarlama değil üretim yine belirlediğim
için yani pazarlamayı düşünmüyor Peki
dedi Sence dedi
fide üretiminde her şey benim elimde mi
Bak dedim ama şirketin sahibi Müdürüm
her şey dedi benim elimde mi
Ben dedim Evet fiyatı Sen söylüyorsun
bize ne söylesen de biz yapıyoruz hayır
dedi Arkadaşlar bu
ve İsrail'e Yine bir sorun var mı
bir kontrol eder misiniz
bu hemen altıncı slayt da görüyorsunuz
altı slaytı bir biyoloji eş eleyerek bir
tohum çıkardı dedi ki bu tohum olmadığı
sürece ne Bana ne sana ne de bu fideleri
ihtiyaç var Bu nedenle de üretecek sen
tohum üretmeniz başka da bir şey
öğretmene gerek yok çok dikkatimi
çekmişti tohum konusu dönemde ülkemizin
de zaten şu andaki strateji konularından
bir tanesi iki sınıfa başladığımda
fakülteye giderken canlı bir tane
Erasmus yazısı gördüm arkadaşlar Erasmus
hepiniz biliyorsunuzdur Ben Türkiye'deki
ilk pilotu öğrenciler dedim Çünkü
küçücük bir kağıtta yazıyor erasmus
öğrencisi arıyoruz hemen yazan hocamın
yanına gittin mi hocam Hadi Hocam ben
gitmek istiyorum dedi ki yabancı dilim
var mı var Anadolu Lisesi mezunuyum de
eğitimlere gir sınavlara gir geçer Sen
de göndereceğim ve ilk pilot öğrenci
olarak gideceksin arkadaşım bir tanesini
zorlayarak o sınavlara girdik ve bir
sınavları geçtik Varşova tarım
Üniversitesi'nde erasmus öğrencisi
olarak eğitim almaya hak kazandık
şu anda doktora yapan Royale diye bir
hocam vardı bize derslerde DNA nedir
Genetik nedir Gen nedir al eldedir
bunları üretiyordu Hocama dedik hocam
Siz anlatıyorsunuz bunları bunların
Tamam soyut kavramlar Yani ben bunları
nerede göreceğim dedi ki gel laboratuara
ben sana laboratuvarda anlatırım beş gün
laboratuvarda bulaşık yıkadım arkadaşlar
Bulaşıkları yıkadıktan sonra bize DNA
nasıl izole edilir nasıl çıkarılır
bunları gösterdi ve günün sonunda Artık
bizde Ne ayı elde etmeye öğrenmiştik
konuştuğum yıllar 2003 şimdi DNA
izolasyonu Biz kendi laboratuvarımızda
yaklaşık yarım saatte çıkarıyoruz o
dönemde birbirine ayı üç günde çıkara
biliyorduk
daha sonra dedim ki Hocam hocam biz bu
DNA teknikleri nerede kullanabiliriz
neler yapacağız biz bunları tohum
üretimlerinde hibrit tohum üretimlerinde
anne ve baba adaylarının tespitinde
kullanıyoruz dedi işte orada zaten Benim
aradığım soru oyduğu cevapla buydu ve
dedik Hocam ben bu tohum üretiminde
öğrenmek istiyorum ama biz bunu yaz
döneminde yaparız dedi Eğer yaz
döneminde staja kalırsam ve arazide
çalışacağım ben sana bunu öğreteceğim
hemen Türkiye'deki hocam yazdığı hocam
Benim kalmam gerekiyor Ne gerekiyorsa
yapalım ve kaldık
Tabii arazinin dikimi çapalaması bakımı
bitkiler arkadaşlar günlük bakım ister
Bunlar olduğu sürece bakım olmadığı
sürece bitki geliştirme şansımız yok
Bize arazide bu konuları Öğrettiler
gördüğünüz gibi hem laboratuvarda
çalıştık o dönemde hem de arazide tohum
resimlerini
gerçekleştirdik
Türkiye'ye döndükten sonra
Türkiye'deki tohumculuğu hibrit sebze
tohumlarının standart size tohumlarını
Türkiye'de neler ekilir Dünyada neler
var Bunları araştırmaya başladım sonuç
olarak bir gün araştırma yaparken
Hollanda'nın en büyük tarım
üniversitelerinden en araştırmacı tarım
Üniversitesi'nden bir tanesinde bir
tohumculuk seminer eğitim olduğunu
duydum Hemen yazdım dedim ki Ben
öğrenciyim BİM katılım parasını öde ama
bu programı kalmamalı paramı karşılarım
beni dedim kabul eder misiniz onlar da
tabii ki dedi ve kabul edildim gittim 45
günlük bir eğitim aldık 45 günlük
eğitimin sonunda arkadaşlar dünyanın en
büyük tohum üretim tesislerinden bir
tanesini bizi ziyarete götürdüler orası
da burası bu ıhhh hala resimleri halen
ve binaları her şeyi hala kafamda
canlanır ve benim ilk hedeflerim ilk
Araştırma Merkezi kurma hedefim burada
gerçekleşti arkadaşlar Ee hedeflerim
tamamen somut lun etti ve heyecan verici
ve hala da bana heyecan verir bu
gördüğümüz resimler beni her zaman
duygulandırır Arkadaşlar
bu Türkiye'ye döndüm Türkiye'ye
döndükten sonra özel bir ıslah ar-ge
şirketinde ıslahçı yardımcısı olarak işe
başladım bu süreçte benden sorumlu oluşu
Şefim Müdürüm Recep Bey dedi Ben de onun
ıslahçı sistem Aydın Bana ilk gün dedi
ki arkadaşım Türkiye'de mes 38 beştir
bizde mesailer sabah 5'te başlar akşam
8'de biter serada bitki olduğu sürece de
pazarda çalışırız bitki dinlenmez Ben
dedim Hay hay kabul ediyorum ve çok uzun
süre Arkadaşlar biz biz Yaklaşık dört
yıl süreyle neredeyse hiç dinlenmeden
çalıştık Peki her şey böyle güllük
gülistanlık mı Hayır ne yazık ki iş
hayatında ciddi olumsuzluklar da var
peki bu olumsuzluklar nelerdir
ama
biz 4 yılda şirketin belirli kıvama
getirdik ama plansızlık başımızda buna
yetersiz liderler ve yetersiz sermaye
yüzünden arkadaşlar iflas eşiğine geldik
artık ar-ge yapamaz olmuştuk Peki ne
yaptık
Ben hedeflerim tutmadığı için o dönemde
başka bir yatırımcıyla tanışmıştım ve
dedi ki gel bu tohum işini birlikte
yapalım sana dedi bir kısımda ortaklık
vereceğim sen de bu işi yürüt tamam
dedim ertesi gün işe başladığımda 3.
yılın sonunda Arkadaşlar biz üç ülkeye
sebze tohumu ihraç eden ve Türkiye'nin
en bilindik firmalarından Biri haline
gelmiştir Pek yine her şey güllük
gülistanlık mı gitti Hayır yetersiz
muhasebe kötü Yönetim çabuk büyümeye
çalışmak ve yanlış ortakları seçiminde
ortak seçiminden dolayı bizi arkadaşlar
iflasın eşiğine geldik o kadar depresif
bir hal dedim ki hiç unutmuyorum
migren ağrılarından dolayı kendimi
yaklaşık Ya bir hafta yoğun gün Kapalı
bir oda o kapkaranlık bir oda ve tamamen
depresif bir durumdaydım ne yapacağımı
da bilmiyorum
İnsan bazı durumlarda bu tarz şeyler
artık on yıla Baktığı zaman hiçbir şey
yapmadığını tamamen çöpe attığını
düşünüyor esasında öyle değil
bir hava almak için Dışarı çıktığımda
yanımda telefonların bilgisayarın
kesinlikle yoktu Bilgisayarımı açtığımda
bilmeye geldi yurtdışında tanıştığım bir
arkadaşım şöyle yazmışlar tek başına
gelenleri Duydum çok üzüldüm
bunların şirketi amerikada aydı
Ortadoğu'da oturak domates ıslah
programı açmayı düşünüyoruz bunun başına
gelir misin Bir şartımız var Amerika'ya
yerleşmek zorundasın dedim Ay ne demek
Hemen başladık yazışmaları Ben artık
gideceğim hem gitmeyi düşünüyorum
yarışmalara başladık Her şey yolunda
hiçbir sıkıntı yok o dönemde bir
arkadaşım aracılığıyla Türkiye'nin en
büyük gıda şirketlerinden bir tanesinin
yaş meyve sebze gıda şirketlerinden bir
tanesini sahibi ile tanıştım bana dedi
ki ben dedi Türkiye'de tohumculuk yapmak
istiyorum gel dedi Bu işi birlikte
yapalım dedim A Bang Kusura bakmayın Ne
demek gidiyorsun dedim böyle böyle bir
durum oldu Ben de bundan dolayı
gidiyorum Hayır efendim dedi Sen de bu
yetenek varsa dedi ki ben yetene çok
inanan insan değilim Onu da söyleyeyim
başarı ve Disiplin olduğu sürece yetenek
kendisi gelir
dedi ki sen de bu yetenek varsa sende bu
beceri varsa sen bunu zaten Türkiye'de
yapabilirsin Türkiye'de de yeteri kadar
Antalya'da yeteri kadar Doğa var mı su
var mı güneş var mı ışık var mı Toprak
var mı sen dedin Ne diye başka bir yere
gidiyorsun başka bir yerde çalışmanın
kolay mı olduğunu düşünüyorsun dedi bu
işi yapabilecek Sen burada yap Sen zaten
dedi yapmıyorsun sen şu anda sadece
kendi içindeki sorunlardan dedi
kaçıyorsun çok düşündüm doğru eve
geldiğimde Ertesi gün ne kadar neredeyse
çıkmadım Sadece bu cümleler düşündüm ve
doğruyu Çünkü benim hedeflerime tam
anlamıyla uçuşuyordu
bütün arkadaşlarımı topladım yaklaşık
sekiz dokuz kişilik bir ekip tek
arkadaşlar sekiz dokuz kişiye dedim ki
Arkadaşlar ben bir işletme kuruyorum
ancak hiç param yok Gidecek yerim de yok
benim dedim çalışır mısınız hepsi
güvenir bana sağ olsun Hepsi hala
hepsiyle yaklaşık 12 yıldır birlikte
çalışıyoruz hepsi benimle birlikte
gelmeyi kabul etti ama gidecek inanın
bir yerimiz bile yoktu Ben de bana bu
işi teklif eden bu yatırımcı arkadaşım
aradım Dedim ki benim Gidecek yerim yok
Ne yapabilirim bana bir adres gösterdi
arkadaşlar oda Burası burayı Biz
kiraladık bizim için biraz önceki
hedeflerimi gördünüz değil mi Burası da
bizim için o dönemde sarayda
bu prefabrik tamamen seralar çok eski
sıralar bakımsız Onu bizim için bir
saray Çünkü gidecek yerimiz yok zaten
yani bir şeyler yapmak zorundayız Ama
param da yok ne yapabilirim diye
düşündüm o dönem değil küçük ihracat
yapıyorum demiştim ya kredi kartında
3750 MİT'in vardı çok iyi hatırlıyorum
üç tane uçak bileti aldım ilk başta
gördüğüne gittim Sonra Mısır'a gittim
Sonra İran'a gittim ve buradaki
müşterilerime dedim ki sizin bu ürünlere
ihtiyacınız var var mı var pek ederim
Size yarı yarıya iskonto iskonto ama
dedim paraları peşin öderseniz Ben de
size üç ay sonra tohumlarını teslim
ederim hepsi kabul et Türkiye'ye
geldiğimde hiçbiri parasının yarısını
ödeme arkadaşlar hepsi tamamını dedi hiç
ki hiçbiri iskontoyu kabul etmemişti
indirimi kabul etmemişti ve artık ben
Arabayı çalıştır Mıştım ve tekeri
döndürmeye başlamıştım Peki daha sonra
ne oldu Yaklaşık dört yıllık iyi bir
ar-ge iyi bir planlamanın sonunda 95 Bu
bir ekiple şu anda Türkiye'nin İso
Kalite Belgesi ile yönetilen Ender
araştırıcı kurulu şirketlerinden bir
tanesini oluşturduk şuanda 160 bin
metrekare alanda kendi DNA
laboratuvarımız kendi tohum üretim
istasyonlarımız ve kendi paketleme
ünitelerimiz de şu anda hem dünyada hem
de Türkiye'de hizmet vermekteyiz
baktığımız zaman Türkiye'de artık
bilinmiş bir marka dünyada özellikle
Ortadoğu doğu ülkelerinde bilinen bir
marka durumundayız Pekin şimdi Coğrafya
kader mi Öncelikle
Ha bir de coğrafya
meslek seçimi coğrafyada coğrafya
belirler mi arkadaşlar Eğer coğrafyasına
fındık ve zeytin ülkemizde üretiliyor
Evet bu kader ancak bunları Siz bir
ürüne bir markaya çevirirseniz ve mi
arkadaşlara bilirsiniz yani fındığı bir
kaliteli bir çikolata kıvamına getirip
zeytini bir zeytinyağı kaliteli bir
zeytinyağı kıvamına getirip sata
biliyorsanız artık Coğrafya kader
olmaktan çıkmış oluyor dolarak
arkadaşlar hayallerin hepsi birer tohum
dur ve Sizlerde eklediğiniz tohumun
hasadını yapamazsınız Çok teşekkür
ederim